c'est un camp de réfugiés comme tant
d'autres dans cette région du nord de
l'ethiopie au tigré plusieurs centaines
d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
s'entassent dans des camps de fortune où
les conditions de vie sont désastreuses
ils n'ont pas eu d'autre choix que de
fuir la guerre qui minent la province
depuis le début du mois de novembre
dernier
il n'y a pas de nourriture il n'ya pas
d'abri rien pour nos besoins
fondamentaux
même si vous le pouvez vous devez vous
adresser au monde pour qu'ils viennent
rapidement
oui il nous souffrons beaucoup je ne
peux pas l'expliquer nous sommes venus
ici à cause de la guerre on nous a volé
nos affaires et nos animaux ont été pris
le conflit oppose le premier ministre
habib ahmed prix nobel de la paix 2010 9
au front de libération du peuple du
tigré parti politique qui contrôle la
région depuis de nombreuses années et
qui s'oppose ouvertement au pouvoir
central d'addis abeba l'intervention
militaire éthiopienne lancé sur la
région le 4 novembre dernier s'est
officiellement terminée le 28 novembre
selon le chef du gouvernement fédéral
une version contestée par de nombreux
médecins qui déplore des violences
depuis plusieurs semaines pour moi ce
serait une vaste blague parce que nous
recevons constamment des patients
blessés par la guerre ce sont tous des
civils
et nous recevons constamment des
patients blessés si quelqu'un dit peu
importe qu'ils aient si quelqu'un dit
qu'il n'y a pas de guerre aux tigres et
je considère que c'est une blague
une situation instable dénoncées par les
etats-unis qui viennent d'envoyer un
émissaire sur place pour exprimer leurs
inquiétudes
washington craint d'assister à je cite
un nettoyage ethnique
une accusation rejetée par le pouvoir
éthiopien preuve de sa bonne volonté
et addis abeba a demandé le lancement
d'une enquête conjointe sur le conflit à
michel dossche les haute commissaire des
nations unies aux droits de l'homme
une requête acceptée ce jeudi et qui
devrait aboutir sur le lancement d'une
mission onusienne dans le pays le plus
rapidement possible car le temps presse
le conflit aurait déjà fait plusieurs
centaines de morts et des dizaines de
milliers de réfugiés